Luke how are you by Conan I'm great good
to see you nice to talk to you and I
think you're doing a real service by
helping put people in a good mood so
thank you well I like to think that I'm
the real hero in this crisis so thanks
for pointing that out
you know I appreciate it we're where are
you right now can you show me just a
little of your atmosphere I want to get
a sense of what it's like look in
quarantine Luke that is a lot of chopped
wood that's enough hugh jackman split
all that for me that's one of the nice
things the way Hollywood's kind of
banded together I don't even know the
guy but I mean is there anything he
can't do he can sing he can dance great
actor you don't even know him
you don't know the man I don't know the
man Cohn and he showed up whipped his
shirt off and you know he's built like
you he's an Adonis yeah he spent the
better part of an afternoon sweating in
court of wood I just I grabbed a glass
of lemonade and just kind of took it all
in it was just kind of amazing Wow
no well you know look he's known to do
that and good for him and a shout-out to
Hugh Jackman for just randomly cutting
firewood for celebrities you know Luke I
worry about you are you staying busy you
know you look alone there and that
bungalow how are you keeping busy I've
been just trying to kind of do what
everybody else is doing which is yeah
just kind of stay in but yeah it's funny
oh oh I'll have these conversations with
my mother who's 80 and lives in Texas
and she'll say you know what did you do
today or what did you do this week you
know what did you get done I got a
little work done and made a few calls
but really not much you know because
I've just been following the you know
the state guidelines and she'll kind of
imply that I'm kind of being lazy by not
doing anything and getting out there you
know it gives me this feeling like she's
like John Gotti or like Tony Soprano she
wants me out there
you know pandemic paid me global crisis
thing where is my money
she takes kind of a tougher approach to
all this but no she actually she's been
doing well and she's not been asking me
for money yeah well let me ask you this
you know everyone's obsessed with the
same thing which is none of us are
really getting haircuts if we're getting
them like I've trimmed it some on the
sides but it's getting real floppy on
top what are you deciding to do yeah
well I mean you've your hair has always
been a big thing since you got started
and it's always had a lot of volume a
lot of body but for me it's like I
always wait till I get a job to get a
haircut so yeah I've been having the
same problem everybody else is it's like
I did wait I didn't wake up one morning
I looked in the mirror and I was like I
got Chris Gaines haircut you remember
when Garth Brooks had his grunge
alter-ego Chris Gaines who got like a
cut he was like a countrified Kurt
Cobain that to wake up one day and you
know people talk about waking up and you
know I looked in the mirror and it's
like I didn't know who I was I looked in
the mirror and I was Chris Gaines and it
shot the hell out of me that's not a
good feeling so yeah I might have to
just yeah invest in some Clippers